how are you feeling you've had some time
to sit with it about being evicted you
know how are you feeling now um i mean
i'm definitely a little relieved to be
back in the wild wild world and you know
getting to sort of enjoy the comforts of
my own home and be around my animals and
all that good stuff but i don't know i'm
still just like mind blown i still don't
really understand what happened and i
was really hoping that julie chen was
gonna tell me that you know they had a
four-person alliance that i wasn't aware
of or something because
none of it made any sense to me i was
like i just don't understand what's
happening
so
did you i don't know if you've had the
chance to but have you looked at like
live feeds or anything to see sort of
like i have not had the chance yet so um
you know i think it's going to be very
interesting though to see how it plays
out because i think they're going to get
eaten alive now
yeah what
at least for me watching it i was like
so frustrated obviously and i can't
imagine how you were feeling um but
what do you feel like hurt more was it
this whole plan that misha and toddrick
concocted or was it that um carson and
cynthia believed it
um i mean it was both you know for me it
was you know i knew they were going to
do something because that's kind of like
how they were you know per they they
were very personal and so um i even said
to cynthia you know if if they come to
you if you have any concerns like come
to me talk to me
please and you know and they just didn't
even give me the opportunity to talk to
him or even really defend myself and
then they had the whole house like yeah
okay you know and what frustrated me the
most was not so much that todrick and
misha went and lied to them and told
them all these things
um i knew they were gonna do that i just
um in in it and i and i understand why
like cynthia and carson might believe it
because of the paranoia
that can happen in that house but more
than anything it was like
you're you're just you're not even
giving me an opportunity to speak you're
not even listening to me and i've shown
you in my actions over and over that i'm
here for you and i didn't want to give
misha and todrick the
the the power to see as you know that
they destroyed that alliance that they
you know that they i didn't want to give
them that power to see us fight
yeah
um
do you
do you wish there was something
you could have done or done differently
uh that you look back on like you're
like if i just in this one thing maybe
you know that wouldn't have happened or
anything like that
yeah i would not i wouldn't have
used my power veto
you know i definitely would have kept
carson up there and he would have went
home and then probably cynthia the final
week and then i still would have had
chris kirkpatrick on my team
and then in that case i would have been
able to um you know at least have a
fighting shot against misha and todrick
down the road
um you know chris has been so supportive
of you like on social media and
everything has he reached out have you
guys gotten to
yeah and teddy as well he definitely
reached out and was like um
uh you know like girl you did good he
was just so supportive and he's you know
that's chris though for you he's just a
really great guy and you know when i
lost him in the house it i felt it you
know everyone sort of had their teammate
and you know i was just like a lone
loner in there at one point it got very
lonely i felt like i keep using the
analogy of like you know i felt like i
was like in eighth grade and i was like
being bullied on the playground you know
at one point but you know i held my head
high and you know i did the best that i
could do and i look back and i'm just
really thankful for the whole experience
um
uh sorry my brain just
had a little brain just for a second
um you know we
uh when you went into the house you were
a little worried about
you know how your past comments about
chloe we're going to impact you know
yeah and everything do you guys ever get
to talk about that and like would you
you guys seem good like would you
consider him a friend now
yeah you know he's a great person uh he
was nothing but like nice to me in the
home you know he talked about chloe and
how you know he still had feelings for
her and you know he acknowledged like
some of his mistakes in the past and
things that he wish that he had done
differently and i thought that was very
commendable to do
um i definitely um you know did not tell
him that i accidentally called her a
name on the wendy williams show back you
know it's not one of my finest nor one
of my proudest moments at all and if he
didn't bring it up i wasn't going to
either
it's something i really would like to
forget very much in my my deep deep past
um so uh but you know yeah um he was
very open you know he knew that my
ex-husband was now engaged to a
kardashian as well so we knew we kind of
had that in common and dealing with that
family so to speak so um but yeah he was
nothing but you know he was just a nice
person and it was actually nice to see
that side of someone
you know it's it's just you know
you know in hollywood you hear things
about people even todd bridges you know
you've heard all these crazy things
about people and then when you meet them
and you hear their sides and their
stories and you see their humanity and
you see them you know you're like wow
you know i guess we all get sucked into
that that media world sometimes it's
just refreshing to you know see that
okay these are these are real people
with good hearts and you know they're
doing their best well it's nice um i do
want to also i have to discuss with you
this um your exit which
was amazing
sorry
you said you know like oh toddrick i'm
gonna turn the jury against you um i
know you told julie it's like you can't
control obviously what they do yeah was
it to get into his head a bit was it
like all of that and then he was already
he was already in that house counting
jury votes like he in his head is like
i'm in final two i need this person's
vote that person vote and he was
lobbying already and saying things to
people i mean that's one of the reasons
why i did not want to work with todrick
because he made things like very
personal
uh he played victim a lot
you know and but meanwhile you know he
just he didn't say nice comments about
people
and then you know and he just he was
already sort of like like counting jury
votes and i just was like
you know i didn't i didn't like it
um if
you know you're laughing just so you
know he was clapping and dancing you
know as i was walking out the door so
that's why i said what i said it was
like okay dude like you won like can you
just at least let me walk out the door
like you know i've been nothing but like
you know held my head high and you know
tried to walk out with class
um you
um are a big fan of big brother
obviously celebrities with brother jury
works differently if you were to rate
toddrick's jury management what would
you say
uh say that again sorry uh you're you
know being familiar with the uh big
brother you know that
celebrity big brother operates
differently than
regular big brother and that you know
the jury isn't sequestered and people
will see things how would you say that
todrick managed his jury management i
don't think he's managed it very well at
all i think there are a lot of people
who are a little annoyed and not happy
with todrick at the moment so i don't
think i have much work to do
yeah um i know at the end you said yo go
top bridges is that who you would like
to see go yeah
yeah yeah todd is just you know the one
thing i love about todd is you know he
pl he pretends like he's okay going home
or he pretends he's not playing the game
but he's definitely playing he knows
exactly what he's doing
and you know and he's just a nice person
and i would really like to see someone
with a good heart and where this
opportunity could really help them in
life so
um that's why i would like to see todd
win
what surprised you the most about
playing this game
it's it's much more um
mentally physically emotionally
all-encompassing you know and you know
it's when you don't have
um you know like vices of any kind
whether it be television or your phone
or pencil or wine whatever you know um
you you just have
you know you just sit and think all day
so that's where like the paranoia kicks
in or you know you just start looking at
all the different
you know ways that things could happen
or unfold and i found that to be like
you know more intense than i thought it
would be but
um it was it was still just an
incredible experience
would you ever you know if they were
gonna do a celebrity all-stars or
something like that would you ever
do it again
yes i i think i would um i just
definitely need a little decompression
time and um i think it would actually be
even better going in if there ever was
an all-stars or something like that
because i would just really be more
mentally prepared for the actual
you know the whole
style of the filming and being watched
24 7 and things like that
and you'd be playing with people who had
previously played before yeah exactly
people who knew the game would be
exciting
i spent so much time explaining the game
to everybody that i was like okay this
is what's happening it's like and that
was exhausting
um if you let's say they were like hey
who should we cast for the next season
of celebrity big brother who is a
celebrity that you would love to see
uh in that house like in that
environment um i'm a really big fan of
the impractical jokers
and um i think seeing any one of those
guys on celebrity big brother would be
really cool like sal or q or something i
think would be really fun to watch
you